so you guys might have seen this story
was popping up all over the place on
BuzzFeed and Business Insider all over
about this guy that was given a speech
and said he and his partner basically
had invented something that was going to
make the vagina smell like peaches that
was the story that was run all over the
place and then it's sort of got pulled
back a little bit it turns out that he's
just an investor in a company that this
girl created a probiotic that she called
sweet peach and this was to help girls
you know probiotics it helps your
digestive system makes you generally
healthier and this guy who's an investor
he got a little ahead of himself and
basically said it was going to make your
vagina smell like peaches the media went
bonkers with the peach vaginas very
exciting so I it was making me think and
that's why I want to do this story the
vagina I'm a thinker the vagina what's
the deal with the vagina know what
people so okay so it's not going to make
the thing smell like peach vaginas so
but people were excited about it and
that's what i thought was interesting
well it's good if you got to use the
probiotics right because i use it and
that's what makes it smell like pee
version the amateur is the amateur my AG
smells like mackerel he's feeling today
he's feeling it um do you why your
vagina's too smelly peaches been again
this is not going to actually do that I
want to be very clear the store the
woman who was left out of the article by
the two douchebags who uh learn with his
who ran with the story her name is
Audrey Hutchinson and she said I love
this quote it's nothing about sent a
vagina should smell like a vagina and
anyone who doesn't think that doesn't
deserve to be near one right so I like
that that was up so then this guy Austin
Hines was one of the two douche bags
again jack bags he came and he comes
back he goes hey look I never said
anything about making vaginas smell like
peaches uh the commercial product is not
scented the goal is to restore normal
healthy sent he'd be okay there right
except he can't help himself so it goes
on the goal is to restore normal healthy
sent as a byproduct of being healthy and
not having those infections so again he
can't help but smell cuz he still like
uh whose vagina
Mel and I don't want to be near winning
guys in my right high five yeah whatever
alright so again I want a to camera I
want to be very clear about this Audrey
Hutchinson invented this thing it was
never going to smell like peaches that's
just where the investor sort of went off
the deep end with this thing and the
media loved it because it sounds like
something vagina smelling peaches so I
want to ask you to as straight man you
love the vagina you're talking about it
constantly uh would you want your wife's
vagina it smell like peach or another
fruit is there a better fruit for you
I'll South say this that I have a book I
was giving it for my birthday was lost
stories of the Bible and one of the
stories in there is when God comes down
and he says to Adam after he invented II
because where's Eve she says all she
she's taking a bath in the lagoon he
goes I'll never get that smell out of
the fish it's a lost story of the Bible
yeah yeah I barely remember that one uh
you want your vagina the wife's banana
to smell like a fruit or maybe I don't
know like a birthday cake or say
something a controversial yes yes yeah
and I think that that like I mean I
don't have any objection to it as is you
know it's lovely it's a big turn on so
forth but I mean if you could get mango
mango mango that's a thing man you who
wouldn't take you know you enjoy a
chocolate [ __ ] on my could have a
chocolate [ __ ] that would be great so
yeah yeah I didn't mean to put this on
you guys I'm not trying to deflect here
I think that's the end of the show